quand je parlais du totalitarisme doux
de l'idéologie du service public c'est à
dire la sueur administration par une
administration par une bureaucratie une
technocratie une énergie peu importe
à cette époque je faisais une
distinction que je voulais vivre entre
la puissance populaire et le pouvoir
institutionnel
on confond très souvent l'un et l'autre
et donc dans le fond il n'y a de vrais
pouvoirs de politique et donc de
confiance vis à vis du politique que si
ce pouvoir reste ancré dans la puissance
populaire
là encore permettez moi de citer des
saint thomas d'aquin omnis autorit as à
pau poulot toute l'autorité vient du
peuple et c'est cette puissance qui fait
que ben ça donne une légitimité à haut
pouvoir institutionnel
or actuellement il n'y a plus cet
ancrage il ya une abstraction de la
bureaucratie par rapport à cette
puissance et du coup il ya une vraie
méfiance de vis-à-vis de la classe
politique mais soyons clairs un
vis-à-vis pour moi d élite la faillite
des élites et quelque chose pour moi de
frappant actuellement parce que tout
tout simplement cette élite c'est
abstrait du peuple regarde et comment
dès qu'il est question du peuple on va
parler de populisme
moi je dis il ya de la part du pouvoir
politique des politiques et de l'élite
en général une pop aux le populo phobie
on a peur du peuple alors qu' il faut
rester enraciné ce qui est le cas dans
les pays nordiques que vous avez cités
ce qui est le cas dans bien d'autres
pays également
[Musique]